invested well or didn't invest well
i'm not comfortable to do [ __ ] i don't
understand and i'm stunned by how many
people do
you hear somebody you respect and you
just jump and that's always a formula
for vulnerability
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
and gary
from you know when you build me friends
and clearly like gained people's trust
and you said you know people are kind of
just like blindly
following random people how do you speak
to people in a way and gain their trust
in delivering
you know value
i i think for me
i earned it
you know over like the timing was good
for me like if this happened in two this
is this is not a
made-up story the second i had my full
full
full eureka moment
which i think everybody has when they
have moments like this i literally stood
up
and said out loud in the middle of my
apartment thank you god
i swear to god i said that i stood up
because why i was saying that was not
like oh i'm gonna make some money or
this is cool i said it because what took
me to get to that place was
everything that i've done for the last
30 years
has now conformed into this
because you have to understand
collectibility supply and demand
storytelling ip marketing community
built like it was
you know for me it was earned most of
the people that bought v friends
if you really look at them and obviously
i have a good sense of them
these are people that had a ton of
context
on me saying a lot of [ __ ] that a lot of
people didn't believe in that ended up
becoming true
and so
you know to me it is my greatest honor
and my greatest fear v friends it is my
greatest honor and my greatest fear but
i'm afraid to let people down thus
ruining my reputation
the risk that i put myself into with b
friends is extraordinary i
i i have built my career on my
reputation my all of my businesses and
how i work is based on my reputation
but you did tell me like the day we met
like
when you were exploring friends that
like the rest of your career was nfts
like you were committing everything you
were going all in on this that this was
gonna be the foundation of the rest of
your career it's why the balance of the
fear is
conviction right like i have pure
conviction about this like there is 0.0
doubt in my mind that i'm going to build
one of the most significant intellectual
properties in the world you've convinced
me that
yeah
i was a little skeptical at first i mean
i love what you're doing
for a long time but
i was i just did an interview with
somebody who said here's an interview we
did in 2009 and i asked you to name your
favorite entrepreneur and you went left
field and said vince mcmahon and
explained it was because he was a good
storyteller like for me the vince
mcmahon walt disney thing that a lot of
you that are hardest core with me that
have been following me for a long time
the reason i've always brought those two
people up is
for different reasons they've done the
same thing they made you care about
andre the giant and hulk hogan and
mickey mouse and [ __ ] donald duck you
know like
that's the game and my cu my confidence
in my ability to build patient panda or
accountable ant
is through the roof because i know i
want to do it and i definitely know i'm
capable of doing it one of the things
you said that resonated when we were
drawing all these
was you know like the simpsons started
out looking pretty rough
jimmy this is the funniest thing for me
the community cares so much about
provenance
and then they [ __ ] on me for my art
sucking even though i'm the one who drew
it
right the most non-provenance thing
of course
of course
like the least providence thing i could
have done was use the fact that i had
money and could have hired any artist in
the world
but
i get why they bring that up because
obviously a v friend drawing is not of
the caliber of many of the pfp designs
but i'm not looking to win
the first inning of a nine inning game
right i love it that's one of the things
i think it's really about the strategy
but i think you will be able to build
that next disney uh out of this because
it's not a solid state you're going to
continuously evolve and there's an
important point i don't want to forget
it since we're up here and i know who's
in the room there's another big
conversation that i think is really
misunderstood
right now a lot of people are taking on
the point of view that the community
is going to drive success of a project
and
i think that that's going to end up
being historically incorrect and let me
tell you why i think so
in 1992 when i was in high school in new
jersey
there was a stunning amount of chicago
bulls fans
stunning
today in that same high school there are
none because we're in [ __ ] new jersey
what i don't think people understand is
if the founders and the controllers of
the project are unable to continue to
build success
people will become bandwagon fans and
they will sell their token and go join
another community and right now the
reason they believe is because they have
their financial interest in mind most
people are coming from a point of view
based on their bag
they believe this is going to work
because they have six of them
it's a very dangerous perspective
and i think people are supporting
projects where they don't even know the
founders names let alone if they're
capable of building a property
so
i think there's an enormous amount of
carnage coming and the amount of money
that's going to be lost is going to be
staggering
let's have beers
i it's not be it's not be scared
it's be thoughtful
yeah don't let your short-term financial
arbitrage be the foundation of your
point of view
it's clouding the [ __ ] out of people
uh i'm not saying this because like hey
vivren is going to win because i've been
successful and guess what my success in
building wine library or gary v brand or
vayner
has some nuanced aspects to me being
able to build the friends but it's not a
direct comp
like we have to be more thoughtful
there's a lot that goes into this we're
eights ever you know we were just
talking back there and i was talking
about iphone games so here comes the
iphone some of you remember right and
i was investing then and everyone's like
gary
i i remember one
meeting so vividly the guy's like no
gary you don't get it iphone games are
gonna be huge i'm like no i do get it
iphone games are gonna be huge there's
just gonna be 40 000 iphone games that
come out next month and only one of them
is going to be really successful that's
what's going on with this
like people like no gary you don't get
it it has tokenomics gary you don't get
it we have the ip control gary you don't
game it's going to be in the vetivers
gary you don't get it it's going to be a
[ __ ] tv show i'm like no you don't
get it 99 of those things are the
commodity
they have to execute
this is people's monies and a lot of
people have the majority of their net
worth tied up in their tokens
that scares the piss out of me
by accident
[Applause]
i also am paying attention to you sir
i happen to see that you sold something
for a lot of money uh now i don't know
what you're doing with that money but i
think you've actually
one of you know as we started becoming
friends through this
i was really proud of you i watched you
take some off the you know again aj is
so thoughtful he's always in all these
years he's always like he plays it
different than i play he's like he takes
dollars off the board and he we always
like kind of joke but the reason he
knows this for me the reason i don't is
all of it can go to zero thus i play it
differently because i have conviction
i i'm happy for people that are
taking some dollars off the board and
hedging um
incredibly concerned though i do believe
we are smack in the middle where the
majority of the conversation is about
money and that is always very dangerous
[Laughter]
because they had to make sure i was okay
which which i think is amazing i'm going
to add something to this
the biggest thing that helps me in my
beginning
is
seeking out
the other point of view to the thing
that's emerging as my point of view
i'm going to say this slow because this
could really help people
i get in very early so i would listen to
jimmy a lot and other people and i'm
just learning right and i would start
forming intuition
ideas
and then i would actively
search twitter for the counterpoint
because i think what ends up happening
is people find something they like it
and they go too deep and it becomes an
eco chamber and it almost like becomes
politics right you see it in the crypto
space a lot unfortunately because of
what happened in 2017 with the ico
meltdowns and things that nature and
because you know the bitcoin community
is very passionate the ethereum
community
and because it's money
like
again this reminds me so much of web 2
except for one thing everything's so
transactional and the money's here from
day one not in five or six years
and so i'm i i think one thing to think
about is like
you know
and you know this jimmy one of the
things that i really wanted to
understand was dangerous enough
on the tech to not get really caught i
don't want to know everything but i
needed to understand mainnet layer 2
bridging like if i'm going to buy these
punks and ethereum disappears can i
bridge them over the plasma bear saga of
the dying bear like you know i really
really really really did a lot of
homework
like and i think you need to do that and
when you get comfortable with one point
of view go here like after i decided
punks was the most important thing that
i wanted to do i spent the next 72 hours
reading every anti-punk point of view
that i could find
and i think people don't do that you buy
six
cool cats which are awesome big shout
out to them and you go into that discord
and you go into that twitter and you're
pot committed
like with no thought of anything else
because you want those things that you
minted for
yeah you you just want especially after
what we saw with the incredible nature
of board ape and with punks everyone's
looking for theirs
that's all that's happening right now
everyone's looking for theirs everyone's
looking for their be friends for their
punks right and to your point whatever
the compliment i was giving you you have
this long-term project
one of the reasons i wanted to do the
thing we did for
the vayner people why i continue to like
watch it and buy it occasionally is
i just think you're doing this forever
as a matter of fact one of the things i
did the most was when i saw you were
starting to make real money on board
yeah and started liquidating some i was
watching very carefully
like
how you were gonna act
you know it's a very different life when
you start having money when you start
having famous people inviting you to
their parties i'm i was really watching
you strictly for two core reasons i care
about you and if i thought you were
going to lose your mind a little bit i
was going to tell you nicely
no no really in like the most amazing
way like hey brother i've seen this a
lot keep this in mind and two because i
believe in your project and i want to
keep buying it and if you're going to
lose your mind i don't want to buy your
project
i think i'm very fortunate you came
along because you have a very positive
message overall it's really made me
think a lot more about how i act
outwardly being around you and hearing
that positivity so thank you
appreciate all of you what you guys do
to help educate and bring bananas into
the space um
that we are very early i think we all
know we're very early
outside however we've got artists in the
room we've got investors we've got
entrepreneurs like myself outside of
investing in individual projects
potentially creating our own what are
some other things we need to be thinking
about doing to take advantage of the
fact that we are so early in this space
and we know every company every brand
eventually is going to be coming into
this and i want to know i was here early
and i created these things or got
involved in these things to really take
advantage of this
my belief is the first thing one does
with information
that's early is sharing it
you know the first thing you can do is
start your own discord and have 87
people in there and have great intent to
bring them value the biggest problem
with the influencer marketing space the
web 2.0 space and the web 3.0 space is
people start with the starting point of
how am i going to make money
and then they work backwards the reason
i am going to consistently win for the
rest of my life is i start with what's
in it for them
and so
the best thing you can do is start with
what's in it for them
right but then i think the other thing
you have to do is deploy self-awareness
some people here really want to do
events and like so you start an events
company that focuses on web 3. other
people really love merchandise like
every you have to understand
the web 3 concept really the block
changes specifically what nfts mean and
the way we you know i've been thinking a
lot lately if these are gonna actually
be called nfts in seven years because i
remember when everything was called a
web 2.0 site not a social media site
like that's how early we are i'm like i
wonder if this name is going to stick
right but the concept of what it is it's
going to be every contract in the world
all of them
so like i don't know what you're into
but everything's in play everything is
in play you can build the most
successful
gym franchise in the world like an
equinox right
by being smarter about what an nft means
i
this is ridiculous i with no promotion
ahead of time in late august
created one of the biggest selling books
of all time
of all time
like
guys
12 and a half
outsold all my other books combined and
all my other books are new york times
best-selling books
so that was me using the platform to
create an event there is literally
nothing you can say vicky's [ __ ] ice
cream business could be 10 times bigger
if she understands i know rob if she
understands
those books
i get it but
but
so andy i think that's that was my point
in 2006 seven and eight with the with
social media
i understood
because i think about communication
that
social was gonna change the way we voted
had political view look what's happened
because of social that's not i love how
people like it's ruined everything i'm
like you liked mainstream media when we
had the highest levels of dictatorships
and fascism and like like but this is
that big there isn't a business that you
can mention to me right now that an nft
layer understanding of what that could
mean won't touch right now we're too
literal it's a pass
it's a collectible we're so early this
is how everything will be done
[Music]
and one thing when you go to that
journey
don't be scared to say i don't know the
quickest way to ruin so many of you have
lost by faking the funk and somebody
that knows saw it and you lost equity
my greatest strength is to stay very
narrow when people like gary you say the
same [ __ ] i'm like till the end
i don't want to talk about things i
don't know
and and i think a lot of people in early
spaces i saw it heavy in web20 a lot of
people that were early felt the pressure
to fake that they were an expert
destroyed them
it's okay talk about what you know
all right hey jimmy gary my name is
tyler nft
how are you
today uh my question is to ask what do
you think is the best strategy or the
most organic way for us to be spreading
awareness and onboarding new people into
what three
i don't know how terrible my solution is
but the way that i've known about
bringing people into web3 has been to
give them a rising nft you know have
them set up uh
and then sign up for notifications and
they can start getting their offers and
that really
hits them instantly with their personal
crack and their host
so that's
um
i agree with that by the way i do think
giving a little nickel bag always works
um
i i
i
took a very specific approach
which was i was at you know everyone's
in different places once i realized what
was going on i took a very big
responsibility to go to other people
that i knew had major platforms and
desperately try to educate them
so that when they came
they would be giving out good
information
right and we can do that in different
ways so that's what i did but that's not
for everybody because i had a point of
my career where i had influence over
influencers i think the best thing we
can all do
is communicate in a 360 world the
biggest mistake that this audience is
doing is trying to convince their normal
friends
biggest mistake it's so hard
it's it's a complete and utter waste of
time
because what i think is much more
powerful than convincing is conviction
you just need to execute
they'll come
you trying to convince
is literally wasted energy that hour
that you tried to convince your
co-worker could have been an hour that
you spent learning about immutable or
poly
or cardano or what bridging means or
what like like you're wasting time
convincing i promise back to us being
early this collective room is wasting an
ungodly amount of time trying to
convince
just have conviction you get sharper if
you believe in it so much they'll end up
being here all my friends told me nobody
would buy [ __ ] on the internet when in
1995. all my friends told me that
twitter was the stupidest thing of all
time because who cares what you're
eating or who's walking a dog
commencing is just your insecurities
showing up have conviction get stronger
in your craft they will show up if
you're right
[Applause]
i'll go first because you can answer
deeper
i
believe in the market
i have no feelings towards it what
here's what i mean by that
if they don't figure it out another
chain's going to and it's gonna be a
problem and i'm okay no matter how much
eat i sit on or if i convert it to other
things the way i think about the gas
wars is the market is the market is the
market
go ahead
yeah i'm incredibly comfortable you know
i'm you know i'm doing series 2 for a
very specific reason series one sooner
than i thought series one got too
expensive too fast
and i want a lot of more people in our
world and a lot of people want to be in
our world and i have to give a second
bite at the apple it's even why i did
the book thing right
but
much later down
three years from now if i do a series
three
i can do it anywhere
i i really like the way eats scales in a
lot of ways and how many developers on
it but the gas thing is a real thing to
a lot of people
now that being said
everyone's big promises on other chains
also have the same problem that they
didn't expect right so i'm watching i
and and much like every project when i
tell you
that every day i root for
board ape
cool cats world of women i i hate
and i don't like using that word i hate
that people are [ __ ] on other
projects because they think that helps
theirs
it's the worst human behavior i root for
every [ __ ] project because i think
the world is abundant
it's the same way i think about chains
i all you know i love aetherium but like
i don't have any negative feelings
towards any of the other chains in fact
i have a lot of positive feelings and
i'm incredibly curious i hate that i'm
so busy because i want to do more on the
other platform seoul and cardona oh i
want to see it all and i'm watching very
very very carefully and i'm incredibly
open
to building projects on other
chains and i'm incredibly excited if
nine years from now it's this then
that's that i've always been that way to
me i don't care if it's myspace or
twitter or snap i just want to do what
the consumer wants and i think that's
where people get caught they sit on too
much eat too much soul too much this and
then they're they they're pushing their
own agenda you can't fight the market
nobody's got a big enough platform
nobody's important enough to fight the
reality of it and if the gas wars
continue to upset human beings they will
move
the fact that people have a cynical
point of view destroys my soul and so
you get in the reason i came so hard to
nfts is because the sports card industry
was pushing me out because they thought
i was pumping and dumping when i didn't
sell a single [ __ ] sports card with
this chain with this world i could you
could follow me you could see my
behaviors so i'm like this is [ __ ]
awesome
this is transparency i don't have to get
caught you can see what i'm doing it's
all right there [ __ ] you i don't i would
never ruin my [ __ ] reputation to make
eight dollars on a [ __ ] kevin durant
rookie card you [ __ ] idiot
and i will i make i made enough money
long ago you think i'm really gonna pump
some [ __ ] [ __ ] pfp project to
make 80 000 in 24 hours you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm not
and i know a lot of people do but that's
why i came to this world but i don't
want the power i don't i do not want it
there's nothing in it for me
and i get it but people have to get
educated my whole [ __ ] open seas a
[ __ ] disaster because everybody ear
drops me all this [ __ ] garbage
the biggest problem the you know what
the biggest problem for matic is the
biggest problem for matic is that it's
cheap and that's what's getting dropped
so my subconscious thinks that poly
sucks because of that well i mean drops
specifically are creating like bigger
gaskets i think that like
we would probably all used to be paying
like 100 gas we're going to get a t
which sucks but like maybe we'll pay
that on this fight for like 700 or 800
during the drop that's money left on the
table by the developer
the problem is people are complaining
about their own bad behavior
their cost factoring in the gas
they're they're
90 of the people in the space are trying
to day trade mints
let's let's stop pretending here
let's stop pretending the majority of
people are looking for a financial
arbitrage
and it's the biggest vulnerability
i i love a good garage sale and i love
that arbitrage
but think about why i talk about garage
sales versus all the other financial
arms because it's for the hundreds of
thousands of dms i get that say [ __ ] you
gary v i can't invest in uber or this
and that so i'm like cool i only have
800 bucks i'm like cool let me show you
what i did for a decade when i only had
800 bucks and like you can do things i
listen i love a good flip
what i don't like is hypocrisy
what i don't like is people talking [ __ ]
when you can see their motives right
through their [ __ ]
like people are talking holier than thou
mad at things
they're just trying to buy something get
a pack of cards pull a high one re-list
it like we need to be very honest with
our collective selves or we're gonna
find
i believe that there is a hundred
percent chance of a massive dip because
why do i say that because 90 of the
people are in it to flip and they're
just moving project to project we we
don't have enough demand
to cover the amount of supply you have
so much greed everybody wants to put out
a project
everybody wants the day trade it's 90 of
the action
that that i don't know what i don't know
what people are thinking
but i do know why it's happening money
blinds people like a [ __ ]
it's also about alternatives right
it's also about alternatives right
bitcoin didn't have a ton of
alternatives it was such innovation
today when you have 7 000 projects come
out every month uh i to answer your
question i had a 30 minute meeting with
somebody today for as many of you know
and be friends the plp project right
where you know i'm trying to continue to
bring value
andy i don't know what you thought i
thought that was a ridiculously
impressive meeting why because they've
done it before in a different way
you know i'm now getting very serio this
is a tough one for me let me break it
down
what am i currently looking for
projects with founders who've had
success before
the problem with that is
uber facebook google all companies that
had founders that didn't have success
before
on the flip side it just makes me very
comfortable like it's nice to see you
can see the data you can see the
patterns
right
so i am completely basing my judgment on
the jockey
i
i personally
have learned a lot in these first six
months right the first project i ever
gave any love to because i subjectively
loved the art
was a project where the guy stole the
art
yep
you know and like that was like a real
vulnerability like when people would
razz me for that in discords i was
devastated because i'm like [ __ ] like
what what an unlucky situation for me i
i thought this was about some you know
we all have our subjective opinion about
art
yeah so i mean you know and becky's here
with family like there's you know you
learn so now i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm
like really i'm gonna zoom like i zoomed
danny like i knew a lot about danny
because i'm in new york following a
little bit of the vibe i [ __ ] watched
the [ __ ] vice documentary on him i
[ __ ] zoomed that [ __ ] like
and spent like an hour with him and his
crew i hung up i'm like oh [ __ ] this
reminds me of the asap crew rocky ferg
all this i'm like these [ __ ] are
gonna win
i'm talking about creatures there right
so that's when i you know that i was
comfortable right sarah right now woman
and weapons like i bought her alpha i
looked at it i watched her i watched her
from afar then i bought the alpha then i
watched her after that because after an
event like that after i buy people's
pieces or other people you see what
happens we all know some people go from
nobody knows them somebody puts them on
and all of a sudden they think they're
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the like the lack of
[ __ ] humility is devastating out here
so i first watched then i bought her
[ __ ] then i watched how she handled that
and she tripled down on the good things
which when she then came as many of you
know because seems like a lot of you
followed me close enough that was the
first project i said anything about in
like seven weeks whereas earlier i was
more active so i'm trying to be more
thoughtful i'm petrified of my
reputation and i don't want to get into
where i got to with sports cards i loved
those [ __ ] first two years of sports
cards then when i became too important
to the space
and all the cynicism kicks in and
everybody thinks about short term it put
me in a place where i was better off
saying nothing
right i don't want to be in a place
where i say nothing about projects i
believe in but i'm telling you right now
i will protect my reputation over
everything
to the end and if i have to say nothing
about another project i'm happy to do it
uh i really am i'm incredibly happy to
do it i'll just spend all my time on be
friends and myself that's sad but that's
people's cynical transactional mindset
but i also have to be thoughtful and do
a lot of homework before i co-sign and
i've learned that lesson the hard way